In the name of God, the Most Gracious, the Most Merciful. Praise be to God, and peace and
blessings be upon the Messenger of God, his family, his companions, and
those who follow his guidance.
We have reached the saying of Imam al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him: "The
gate of Paradise is
closer to one of you than the strap of his sandal, and Hell is the same." In
the name of God, and praise be to God, and peace and
blessings be upon the Messenger of God, his family, and all
his companions.
Sheikh Khalid al-Dhafeeri, may God Almighty preserve him, may God bless him and grant him peace,
Imam al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him.
[Music]
He mentioned in it the hadith of Abdullah ibn Mas'ud, may God be pleased with him, who said: The
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said: "
Paradise is closer to one of you than the strap of his sandal, and
Hell is the same." The Imam, may God have mercy on him, mentioned the hadith of Abdullah, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace. This clarifies that obedience leads to Paradise and disobedience leads to Hell. Sheikh, obedience and disobedience may be in the simplest of matters, but they may be the cause of your salvation or the destruction of a
living being.
This is the meaning of Paradise and Hell being closer to
one of us than the strap of his sandal, may
God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music]
Meaning that he may do an action that he considers insignificant.  And it may be a
cause for him to enter Hell. He may do a good deed and consider it
small, but it may be a cause for him to enter
Paradise.
And the meaning of this is that one can do a small deed. This is like the
woman who imprisoned a cat, neither
feeding it
nor letting it eat from the vermin of the earth. That was a
cause for her to enter Hell.
Likewise, like the man who gave water to a dog, or the
prostitute from the Children of Israel who gave water to a dog, and
that was a cause for her to enter Paradise. So
the servant does not know what good deed God has shown him mercy for, and what
evil deed God is angry with him for.
God Almighty
[music]
God, Glory be to Him, and so on.
Therefore, our Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, instructed us
not to withhold any good deed, even if it is just greeting your brother with a cheerful
face. Peace and blessings be upon him
[music].
Rather, he instructed us to do the smallest things, for perhaps they will be a
cause for our salvation from Hell. Protect yourselves from Hell, even with a small act. Peace and blessings be upon him [
music].
Then he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah on the authority of the Prophet, peace and
blessings be upon him, who said: The truest verse a poet has ever said is:
Everything that God has not created is false.  The
Imam, may God have mercy on him, Imam Bukhari, Abu
Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, and
this contains an explanation
that everything in this world is false,
and the wise person should not be influenced
by this world, meaning the affairs of this world,
not the affairs of religion, all of which are false
except for acts of obedience or what helps in acts of obedience. So the wise
person should prefer this world over the
Hereafter and not prefer the fleeting over the eternal.
[Music] He
said, Chapter: Let him look at those who are below him and not
look at those who are above him. The
Imam,
may God have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, on the authority of the Messenger of
God, may God bless him and grant him peace, who said: If
one of you looks at someone who is superior to him in wealth and appearance, then let
him look at someone who is below him.
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, may God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music] And
this hadith guides to an action by which
the servant recognizes the true blessings of God upon him, may God bless him and grant him peace.
This is as in Sahih Muslim, and it is what
Bukhari titled: The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace,
said: Look
at those who are below you and
do not look at those who are above you. Why?
It is more fitting that you do not belittle God's blessings upon you. Under
the blessing,
find the Muslim Hammam, may
God have mercy on him. God, may God bless him and grant him peace
[music]. Glory be to Him, the Most High.
Many people look at what
God has given to so-and-so in terms of wealth and belittle what they themselves have,
even if it is much. But they only look at those who have
more than them, and they look at those who are stronger and healthier.
All of this makes them belittle God's blessings upon
them. The
sheikh said, "If
you look at those who are below you, then you will
recognize God's blessings and thank Him
for them." As for
matters of religion, you look at those who are above you,
not from the perspective of
belittling
what God has given you of blessings, but rather
from the perspective of emulation, so that you
increase in
obedience
and strive to be patient in that obedience. You look at those who are above you,
and this is not from the perspective that you are belittling what God has given
you, but rather from the perspective
that you want to follow them in their
way, those who are above you in obedience to God. So
therefore you can have paid to them, whether they are good
or bad.
Imam al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him
[music], and the intention
meant in the chapter and the hadith
is the intention to do an action or the resolve to do an action, and not merely a passing
thought. He
mentioned the hadith of Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both, on the authority of the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, as he narrated it from
his Lord, the Almighty and Majestic. This hadith is a hadith qudsi (divine saying) from
Ibn Abbas, may God be pleased with them both, on the authority of
God, the Almighty and Majestic. The hadith qudsi states that God has decreed good deeds and bad deeds, then explained them [music], then divided them into four categories [music]. Whoever intends to do a good deed but does not do it,
God writes it down for him as a complete good deed. If he intends to do it and then does it, God writes it down for him as ten good deeds, up
to 700 times, or many times more. And
whoever intends to do a bad deed but does not do it, God writes it down for him as a
complete good deed. If he intends to do it and then does it,
God writes it down for him as one bad deed. The
first category is for the one who intends and resolves to do a good deed
but is not successful in doing it, and he has a
firm intention and resolve to do it. This good deed is written for him.  is the
one who strongly intends and has firmly resolved that he wants to perform a good deed, however, he was not successful through it, and so good in it. This is added to the multiplied good deed, and the multiplication is according to the deed, according to the intention, according to sincerity and certainty, and so on. The third is he who intends to do a bad deed,
then abandons it, on the condition that the abandonment is for the sake of Allah and
not due to an obstacle that befell him and he was unable to
do it. This one is not recorded as a good deed
if the condition for recording a bad deed when abandoned is that it is a
good deed, that his abandonment is for the sake of Allah. This one is
recorded as one
good deed.
And not
mention that this is for the one who did not perform it due to sincerity to
Allah, not
simply because something prevented him
from doing it, away from the affairs. So the one who
intended to do a
[music]
As for the one who does a bad deed, it is recorded for him as one bad deed
[music]. And
this is in it an explanation of the favor of Allah, the Exalted,
upon the servants, where the ratio of good deeds
in these categories became three and the ratio of bad deeds became
one. That is the favor of Allah upon
His servants. May Allah, the Exalted,
preserve us. And
Allah, the Mighty and Majestic, is the One who is mentioned
in some narrations of the hadith, “And none will perish before
Allah except the one who is doomed,” meaning
that after these ratios  Many are the means to success. A
good deed you do will multiply your reward. A bad deed you do and then you refrain from it will be rewarded.
All these are
numerous opportunities for success. Yet, he comes to the
fourth category and commits sins upon sins, thus perishing. That is why
he said at the end of the hadith, "And no one perishes before God
except the one who is truly perished." Meaning, he intended to perish because all
has the means to achieve salvation and be rewarded. However, he destroys himself. Therefore,
he enters the
fourth category where he receives one
evil deed. What is
meant by "the plow of sins" is that
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
then mentioned the hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, who said, "You
do deeds that are finer in your eyes than a hair,
but we used to consider them among the destructive sins during the time of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him."
Abu Abdullah said,
meaning the destructive sins.
Anas, may God be pleased with him, said, "The plow of
sins refers to minor sins."
This expression is found in the hadith of Sahl ibn Sa'd,
that the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "Beware of the plow of
sins."
Sahl ibn
Sa'd said, "The example of the
plow of sins is
like that of a people..."  They descended into the bottom of a valley, and
then came a herd of camels
and camels until they gathered what I saw. They made a great commotion about it, meaning
these insignificant sins multiplied, small sins upon small sins,
with persistence in them until they destroyed him.
We have a sheikh who loves God Almighty,
but God, may God bless him and grant
him peace, brought a herd of people and each of them together, small. And he, may God be pleased with him, used to mention about the Companions
that those who came
after them from the Successors used to do deeds that the
Companions considered to be great.
Why, even though they were minor sins, but they considered
them great
because they did not look at the smallness of the sin,
but rather at the greatness of the One being disobeyed, who is God Almighty. Then
Anas, may God be pleased with him, recited
[music].
So the servant should not be lenient with minor sins, for how many a small sin has become
great through persistence. May God Almighty
preserve
[music]. He
said, Chapter on deeds by their endings and what is feared from them. The
Imam, may God have mercy on him,
mentioned the hadith of Sahl ibn Saad, who
said, The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, looked at a man
fighting the polytheists, and he was one of the
Muslims who was most useful to them,
Saad ibn Sahal, the one who strives, may God bless him and grant him peace.
He said, Whoever loves to look at  A man from among the people of Hell,
let him look at this, may
God bless him and grant him peace. So
another man followed him and kept following him until he was wounded. He hastened his death, so he took the tip of his sword and placed it between his breasts. He leaned on it until it came out between his shoulders.
[Music]
The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said: “A person may
do what
people think is the work of the people of Paradise, while in reality he is among the people of Hell. And he may do what people think is the work of the
people of Hell, while in reality he is among the people of Paradise. Indeed,
deeds are judged by their endings.” [
Music] This shows that the people of the Salaf and the people of faith were very afraid of their endings. [Music]
That is why Sufyan al-Thawri, may God have mercy on him, was very anxious about his endings. He would
cry and say, “
I fear that I am in the Preserved Tablet.”  A wretched man
weeps and says, "I fear that I will lose my faith at
death." This was said by
Sufyan al-Thawri, may God have mercy on him, and by women.
Malik ibn Dinar used to
stand in prayer at night and say, "
O my Lord, You know who will dwell in Paradise and who will dwell in Hell. In which of the two abodes will
Malik reside?"
[Music] [
Music]
The wisdom behind this is that if a
servant knew his end and
knew that he was among the saved, he would be less inclined to worship
and obedience. And
if he knew that he was going to perish, he would increase in wickedness and arrogance.
Therefore, the servant does not know in which of the two abodes he will reside. A
sheikh, may God preserve him, and our
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, used to ask for steadfastness: "
O Turner of hearts, keep my heart firm upon Your religion." May God, peace and blessings be upon him, the Almighty and Majestic.
Among the benefits of this hadith is not judging anyone as a
martyr except for those whom the religious texts indicate are martyrs.
This man fought in jihad with the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and
the Muslims saw nothing but good from him. Yet the
Prophet said he is in Hell. [
And
do
not judge anyone for any reason
except for that which we have proof of in
the revelation. The example
here is this man.]  Who
fought at this time, and the people did
not know his circumstances, where he's going to end up.
And the benefit of this hadith is the prohibition of suicide and killing
oneself, no matter the pain or suffering a
Muslim experiences, whether psychological or
physical. He must be patient and seek reward from
God, the Most High. Also, among the great benefits of this hadith
is the well-known saying of the Prophet,
peace and blessings be upon him,
that a man may perform the deeds of the people of Paradise
until there is only an arm's length between him and it, then the
decree overtakes him, and he performs the deeds of
the people of Hell and enters it. A
servant may wonder
how this man could perform acts of obedience throughout his life, and
then when his appointed time comes...  The book preceded him, so he did the
deeds of the people of Hell and entered it. The
answer is
in this hadith narrated by Sahl bin Saad. A
person may find it problematic how life can be obedience to Allah, however, when the time comes to end, he and the people of Sahl bin Saad. The answer is what the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, said in this hadith, “in what people see,” meaning
that this man does the deeds of the people of Paradise in what
people see, but in reality, it is
hypocrisy and showing off, and he does not want the face of Allah, but
outwardly it is righteous work.
Therefore, this
intention in
his heart, in which he is not sincere, had an effect on him in his bad end.
The hadith of Sahl bin Saad, may
Allah be pleased with him, peace and blessings be upon him, “
those actions in which appear to the people,”
he does certain actions that appear to the people
to be from the
actions of the people of Paradise.
However, the reality is that he
performed these actions perhaps out of
showing off and wting to be heard and
not sincerely seeking the face of Allah.   The
chapter on seclusion is a relief from bad company.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him,
included in it the hadith of Abu Sa'id al-Khudri, who said: An
Arab came to the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, and said, "
O Messenger of God, who is the best of people?" He
said, "A man who strives with his life and wealth, and a man in a
mountain pass,
worshipping his Lord and keeping himself from harming people."
[Music]
This shows
that among the benefits of seclusion—
meaning distancing oneself from people—is being safe from many
sins and
from many evil people and bad company
that pushes one towards sins. The
hadith of
love for God is
seclusion. [Music]
People away from people.
[Music]
[Music] The
seeker of knowledge, the believer, should
sometimes isolate himself. His
seclusion might be in obedience to God, in a mosque, seeking knowledge, in
his library, and so on. It was narrated from Umar, may God be pleased with him, that he used to
say, "Take your share of seclusion." May
God protect him
and
keep him away from people.
Take your share from the isolation. Al-
Khattabi, may God have mercy on him, said, regarding his book on
isolation, that
if the
only benefit of isolation were safety
from backbiting and
from witnessing wrongdoing that one cannot prevent, that would be a great blessing. Al-Khattabi defends the idea that was found
inusion from people. Al-
Khudri, may
God be pleased with him, said that he heard the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him,
say, “A
time will come upon people when the
best thing for a Muslim man will be sheep, which he will follow to the
mountain peaks.” The peaks mean the tops of mountains and places where rain falls, fleeing with his religion
from trials.
Imam Al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, narrated the hadith of Abu
Saeed, may God be pleased with him, from the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
In this hadith, it is stated that the servant must distance himself from the
causes of trials, even if only by fleeing from them.
This also contains a statement of one of the signs of
prophethood,
and his informing us that trials will occur
and increase. The
hadith of
God, peace and blessings be upon him.
[Music]
This also confirms
that the servant,
especially the
Salafi, and especially the caller to Islam, must
distance himself from the causes of trials and keep
his mosque and students away from
every trial, from everything that divides them. My
sheikh is from the bounty of God Almighty.
God, Glory be to Him, and
[Music]
And here is a matter
Many scholars have discussed this topic, specifically the question of whether
mixing with others or seclusion is better. The best
answer to this question came from
Sheikh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah, may God have mercy on him.
[Music]
Sheikh al-Islam Ibn Taymiyyah
summarized his point, explaining
which is better:
mixing with others or seclusion. He
said, "The truth is that mixing with others is sometimes
obligatory and
sometimes recommended. A person
may be commanded to mix with others
or to be alone." He added, "In short, if
mixing involves
cooperation in righteousness and piety, then it is
commanded by
God Almighty. But if it involves cooperation
in sin and transgression, then
it is forbidden." He
said, "Mixing with
Muslims is a form of worship, something
commanded by God and His Messenger, may
God bless him and grant him peace, such as attending
prayers and performing the Hajj rituals." He also
said, "There are times when a
person must be alone with himself, in his
supplication, his remembrance of God, and his self-examination." He quoted
Tawus as saying, "
Yes."  A man's sanctuary is his home; his sight and tongue suffice him. Choosing
absolute solitude is a mistake, and choosing absolute isolation is also a mistake.
[Music]
As for the amount of
solitude or solitude a person needs, and what is best in every
situation, he said this requires special consideration. Each
person has their own ruling.
[Music]
This is the ruling on
which is better, isolation or solitude.
This is referred to in Majmu' al-Fatawa,
Volume 10, page 425. [Majmu' al-Fatawa
425]
He said, "Chapter on the Loss of Trust," and
he mentioned the hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, who said: The
Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, said: "When
trust is lost, then wait for the Hour." He said: "
How is it lost, O Messenger of God?" He said: "When authority is given to those who are
not qualified for it, then wait for the Hour."
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, said:
Trust,
Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, God, peace and blessings be upon him, trust, trust,
Hour, the claim of trust, the
opposite of betrayal. What is meant by its loss is its disappearance,
such that the
trustworthy person is nonexistent or almost nonexistent, and they can be counted
on one's fingers.
My sheikh, from memorization  God is
trustworthy
[music] and
this is one of the minor signs of the Hour.
This is something that has happened and been fulfilled.
This trustworthiness may be in worldly matters and
religious matters. How many have lost and
betrayed in worldly matters: buying and selling, transactions, morals,
disobedience to parents, and so on.
[music]
Religion is betrayed most
by the people of innovation, the people of atheism, and others who
betray covenants and trusts, concealing what
God has revealed, concealing the truth, and spreading falsehood.
God Almighty
mentioned the hadith of Hudhayfah, may God be pleased with him, who said: The
Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, told us two hadiths. I saw
one of them, and I am waiting for the other.
Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, said: Hudhayfah, may God be pleased with
him, may God bless him and grant him peace,
told us that trustworthiness was instilled
in the root of
men's hearts, meaning in the very core of men's hearts. Then
they learned from the Qur'an, then they learned from the Sunnah, peace and blessings be upon him. Trustworthiness [
music]
God, peace and blessings be upon him, meaning that they were
originally trustworthy, good people, and people of good morals. Then
religion, the Qur'an, and the Sunnah came and increased their
morals in firmness.
[music] And he
told us about its removal. He
said: A man sleeps  Sleep takes away trust from
his heart. He
said, "Its effect remains like the effect of time," meaning the blackness of the
color.
Then he sleeps, and it takes away, leaving its effect like a
blister.
Yes, like a blister, like a burning ember. You rolled it on a man, and it blistered,
meaning it swelled. You see it raised, meaning swollen, and there is nothing in it.
Yes,
God willing, you have preceded me. Then
people will begin to trade, and hardly anyone will fulfill their
trust. It will be said, "In such and such a tribe is such and such a trustworthy man."
[Music] And
it will be said of a man, "How intelligent he is! How eloquent he is! How strong he is!" But there is not
in his heart even a mustard seed's weight of faith. It will be said, "In such and such a tribe there is such and such a person who is honest," and a man will be admired for
goodness and strength. And there was a time when I did not
care which of you I traded with. If he was a Muslim, Islam would return him to me. If he was a
Christian, his messenger would return him to me.
But today, I only trade with so-and-so and so-and-so.
This is what was mentioned in the previous hadith about the removal of
trust from hearts, and
that the one described as trustworthy will have it taken from him
until he becomes a traitor. And
whenever he befriends  The traitors have little
trustworthiness
[music]
and his saying here, “And a time has come upon me,” refers to the state of
deficiency in trustworthiness,
because he, may
God be pleased with him, died
after the killing of Uthman. He witnessed the change, may
God be pleased with him. So what would he say if he saw our state and what we are in,
and the state of the Muslims today?
[music]
Uthman, may God be pleased with him,
yes. Then he mentioned
the hadith of Abdullah bin Umar, who said, “I heard the Messenger of God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
say, ‘People are like a hundred camels; you can hardly
find one suitable for riding.’”
Abdullah bin Umar, may God be pleased with them both, may God bless him and grant him peace.
This hadith
was included by Al-Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, in this chapter
because many people are
sick, and
much of this sickness
is due to a lack of trustworthiness.
[music]
The intended meaning of “suitable” here is the noble,
chosen, good-
riding camel that is beneficial.
This indicates
that the one who is detached from this world and desires the
Hereafter is
like this camel,
and like its scarcity
among the camels.
[music] He
said, “Chapter on hypocrisy and showing off,” and
he mentioned in it the hadith of
Jundub, may God be pleased with him, who
said, “The Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, said…”  Hearing is what
God hears, and whoever shows off, God will expose him. This is
my Imam, may
God have mercy on him.
This is a warning against it and an explanation of the danger of showing off and
hypocrisy. Showing off occurs in what is
seen of deeds,
and showing off
occurs in what is heard of deeds.
God, may God bless him and grant him peace,
[music].
This contains an explanation that the reward is of the same kind as the deed, and that
whoever does a deed so that
people will praise him in this world, then
God will expose him in the Hereafter. This is a
hadith of
God, the Almighty and Majestic.
Also, it contains that the
servant should conceal his deeds as much as possible,
except for a greater benefit in which his deeds
become apparent, such as following his example in
obedience, while striving to be sincere in the deed for
God, the Almighty and Majestic. This is with the
servant that he tries his best to do as much as he is able to do. This is in such
people.
The Imam, may God have mercy on him, God, the Exalted and Majestic,
mentioned the hadith of Mu'adh, who
said: While I was riding behind the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, with nothing between me and him
but the back of the camel,
Ibn Jabal, may God be pleased with him. God, may God bless him and grant him peace, and
in the hadith, the Prophet, may God bless him and grant him peace, explained to
Mu'adh the
right of God over His servants and the right of the servants over God. This is a hadith of
God, may God bless him and grant him peace.  God Almighty,
God. As for God's right, it is monotheism.
As for the right of the servants upon God, it is
that whoever achieves monotheism will
enter Paradise, and God Almighty will not punish him.
This hadith explains the
virtue of monotheism and that it is one of the greatest reasons for the forgiveness of
sins and the expiation of evil deeds. The hadith states that
whoever strives against his own desires in affirming the oneness of God Almighty will
attain this great reward.
God Almighty. It also mentions the
virtue of Mu'adh and his good manners with the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon
him. It
also shows the humility of the Prophet, peace and
blessings be upon him, as he made Mu'adh ride behind him.
He said, "Chapter on the humility of the
Imam," and
he mentioned the hadith of Anas, may God be pleased with him, that the Prophet,
peace and blessings be upon him, had a she-camel
called al-'Adhba' that
was never outrun. Then an Arab came on his camel and outran him. This distressed the
Muslims, and they said, "You have outrun the servants!"
Then he, peace and blessings be upon him, said, "It is a right upon
God that He raises up something in this world, but
God, peace and blessings be upon him, will lower it."  Glory be to Him, the Most High. Undoubtedly, one of the
greatest virtues a
believer should possess is humility, as the
seeker of knowledge, the follower of the Salaf, and humility itself.
As At-Tabari
said, "Humility
benefits both religion and worldly life."
God Almighty said, "
Humility benefits both religion and worldly life." Indeed, the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him)
informed us that whoever humbles himself for God, God will raise him in status. Glory be to Him, the
Most High. And
the Prophet (peace and blessings be upon him) said, "God revealed to us to be humble so that no one boasts over another." [Music] Rather, the more a servant increases in status, worship, and knowledge, the more his humility and love for God must increase. This hadith, narrated by Anas, tells of the Prophet's (peace and blessings be upon him) camel being ahead when a
Bedouin came and overtook it.
This affected the Muslims. This demonstrates the Prophet's (peace and blessings be upon him) high standing
in the hearts of his companions,
to the point that they would
not allow another camel to overtake his camel. May
God bless him and grant him peace.
[Music] May
God bless him and grant him peace. All of this
also encourages
avoiding arrogance and urging humility, and it indicates
that all worldly matters are imperfect and
incomplete.
[Music] And in it
The Prophet's good character, peace and blessings be upon
him, and his perfect humility, peace and blessings be upon him, and the
hadith of Abu Hurairah, may God be pleased with him, who said: The
Messenger of God, peace and blessings be upon him, said:
God said: Whoever shows enmity to one of My allies, I have declared war against him, may God be pleased with him. God, peace and blessings be upon him,
God Almighty, and My servant does not draw near to Me with anything more beloved to Me than what I have made obligatory upon him. And when I love him, My servant continues to draw near to Me with supererogatory acts until I love him. And when I
love him, I become his hearing with which he hears, his sight with which he sees, his hand with which he strikes, and his foot with which he walks. And if he asks Me, I will surely give him, and
if he seeks refuge in Me, I will surely grant him refuge. And I do not hesitate about anything I am going to do as I hesitate about the soul of the believer. The dead hate, and I hate to hurt him. [Music]
The hadith emphasizes the obligation to show allegiance to the righteous friends of God,
including the prophets, companions, righteous individuals, saints, and
scholars. May God
Almighty preserve them. [Music] God, the Exalted, the Majestic, and the Most High.
It is incumbent upon the believer to
respect, appreciate, and honor these individuals, and to speak of them
only with praise.
This is one of the differences between the Salafi Sunnis
and the innovators of deviant sects.
This is noticeable, and you have observed it. When
our Sheikh, Sheikh Rabi', may
God have mercy on him, passed away, all the
Sunnis spoke well of him, praying for God's
mercy upon him and asking God to grant him Paradise.
[Music]
I ask God to forgive him and grant him Paradise.
As for the innovators, you have seen the Kharijites, the Muslim Brotherhood, the Qutbists, and
many of the laxists who
cursed him. Some even said, "To Hell with him! What a wretched destination!"
We seek refuge in God from them—the Kharijites, the Muslim Brotherhood, the Qutbists, and many
of the laxists. All of this is because our Sheikh played a significant role in exposing them, refuting them, clarifying their falsehood, and breaking the idols they revered and sanctified, such as Sayyid Qutb and other misguided leaders.
Sheikh Rabi', may God have mercy on him.
[Music]
All of this is because
he called for what the Quran and Sunnah call for: holding fast to the
rope of Allah, not being preoccupied with worldly matters, and not
rebelling against the rulers, for that is evil for
Islam and Muslims. May
Allah have mercy on him. Rabi' Allah, the Exalted, the Majestic, the Most High, may
Allah bless him and grant him peace, the Most High, the Most Glorified. He played a
role in exposing and
dismantling their plans—plans through which they
sought to
destroy Muslim countries, dominate them, and seize power and rule, even if it meant bloodshed and the killing of innocent people. May Allah have mercy on him. All of this is because no head of sedition emerged without our Sheikh confronting it, exposing it, and revealing its shameful nature. No one infiltrated the Sunnah seeking to corrupt the Sunnis without the
Sheikh, may Allah have mercy on him, uncovering and exposing him.
We ask Allah to reward him on behalf of the Sunnis and the
Muslims. The
hadith contains many benefits:
that obligatory acts have a greater reward than supererogatory ones;
that sainthood is attained through abundant obedience, as the
Sufis believe; and
that the closer a servant draws to Allah, the more he becomes one of
Allah's saints. May Allah grant him success, victory, and a swift end.  He
hastened,
saying, “Chapter on the saying of the Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him: ‘
I and the Hour have been sent, and the
Hour is like these two, and the matter of
the Hour is but a blink of an eye or even nearer. Indeed,
Allah is over all things competent.’” Imam Bukhari, may God have mercy on him, peace and blessings be upon him, God Almighty, and the
following,
God Almighty,
mentioned the hadith of Sahl, the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him, who said, “I and the Hour have been sent like this,” and
he pointed with his two fingers,
meaning the middle and index fingers, extending them. The
Imam, may God have mercy on him, peace and blessings be upon him,
[music]
love of God Almighty. The gist of the
hadith and the verse
is the nearness of the Hour
and the speed of its coming, and
that it will come suddenly
[music]. And among the
signs of the Hour is this, one of its minor signs
that has occurred and passed, which is the mission of the
Prophet, peace and blessings be upon him. And the evidence
for
the nearness of the Hour is many, and its meaning is the obligation to
prepare for it.
Then he mentioned the hadith of Anas, may
God be pleased with him, similar to it, and similar to it is the hadith of Abu Hurairah.